do they get me hyped because you have to
be hyped to go through all the different
like it's kind of like Indiana Jones or
like a Big Heist like to get these deals
going you have to do whatever it takes
you have to put yourself out there so
you have to have that fire in you and
the great clients light that fire in me
what do you promise your writers
I don't like looking necessarily like
there's a template because I do think
each
writer is unique and has unique you know
sense of you know priorities for what
they want but I guess when you look at
it maybe not necessarily A promise is
what I guess an expectation of a manager
you know is that they need to be able to
work together and look at like material
and figure out which Concepts may be
more viable and develop them and then
like take them out to Market and you
know doing these things are very very
important you know
to any writer and you know so it's not
just putting somebody in a room because
sometimes like you know you know writers
just go I have a meeting
but why is the me why are you having the
meeting like is there is this person
specifically looking for this kind of
material like like I I think that's also
important it's not just
oh let's just show off like here have a
meeting here because there's some
pointless meetings in Hollywood I'll
tell you like there's meetings that
you'll leave with like they'll give you
a water bottle and you're like I got a
water bottle and that was it like if I
have a meeting
I want my clients to get paid at some
point from that relationship I want to
make sure that it's the right person at
the right time then maybe it's not now
but six months from now
I get a phone call from this producer
and says I absolutely looking for that
writer you know looking for that kind of
writer that I met so there is a there
needs to be pragmatism
from the beginning of like development
of an idea it's taking it out to
establishing a networking industry that
you're not arbitrarily doing something
but I would never just go just write
something or just meet somebody it needs
to have a purpose so that's a lot of my
goal is working in conjunction with a
client sometimes that means also working
with an agent like an agent and a lawyer
or a publicist like there's different
collaborators that could get pulled into
a team and each team's unique and for me
I want to make sure that I have a great
relationship and shorthand with all the
members of the team
what do you not promise to writers
you know
I never like I I never set like a like a
frame like this is
going to be this or it's or it's or it's
not going to be that like I kind of keep
it flexible but what I could say is this
I'm a passionate person I believe in
your work I'm going to do whatever it
takes
to advance you know you know our agenda
so that's just to build like uh either
building a viable business out of a
client or if a client is already a
business how to maintain that business
and make it bigger
and so do they have to exclusively work
with you
you make them sign something where they
would only work with you I I don't I
don't necessarily look at it like
exclusively so like
I work with agents all the time I love
collaborating with the right agent so
like I could have an agent that I have a
good you know already have a good
relationship with and then they have
qualities that they bring to the table
so for me it's not proprietary over the
client I want to get the right agent
ideally the right lawyer and then some
clients might you know want to publish
this maybe specifically for film
festivals or one of the movie movies get
released work with the publicist so to
me it's almost like each client is its
own unique
business that we're working together so
you know a manager and agent could have
multiple businesses running at once it's
different than being a producer you know
where you have a movie most likely you
make the film it gets released everyone
makes their money it's done unless it's
like a franchise or just spin-offs but
let's say it's just a normal film a
client is a is going to always be a you
know building new opportunities and
potentially you could take assignments
or sell something so there's so many
more variables as an individual than it
than it's just a one-off you know movie
that gets released so to me it's just
being
receptive to those needs and seeing
opportunities as they present themselves
what do you look for in a client I think
that like the client that I want to work
with
connects my taste so
I think that like
anybody in this industry just because
like if let's say a manager and agent
passes on them it doesn't mean that
they're not amazingly talented it just
means that maybe that rep has different
tastes like my taste are not like it's
not like math you know it's not like
this indisputable thing it's more like
this is a fact is this person you know
good or bad it's more like I read the
script you know I watch a movie and then
I'm passionate like it moves me
emotionally
because I do think that like you know we
live in a we live like living's hard
like how like just the day-to-day it's
just like you get apathetic you had a
hard day or whatever and sometimes
you're just like all right this day felt
like the next day and you're like
whatever but if you read a really good
script it stops time you're like oh my
God like I'm feeling this writer's voice
like it it just is moving me and that's
the kind of
uh client that I want is that they move
me specifically you know I might they
might not remove the other manager you
know at this company and that's fine or
vice versa there may be a totally viable
client that doesn't excite me but
another manager loves working with them
so it's very specific to my curation is
going to be there do they get me hyped
because you have to be hyped to go
through all the different like it's kind
of like Indiana Jones or like a Big
Heist like to get these deals going you
have to do whatever it takes you have to
put yourself out there so you have to
have that fire in you and the great
clients light that fire in me
um and now beyond that aspect of it we
also need to have like
a good back and forth like you need to
be like hey we're working together
because we like you know we like each
other enough you know it doesn't mean
like oh my God like this client this
client is exactly like me I'm not
looking for me I don't care if they're
different backgrounds everything to me
it's not like I'm looking for like uh I
want to wrap myself I want to write
voices that excite me because I never
seen anything like it that's what gets
me into it so so I'm just meaning that
we have a relationship that
is really about listening to each other
and respecting each other and open to
different ideas and once you have the
the work that makes you
get moving and get going and making
making things happen plus you have that
partnership where we could adapt to like
we're saying the chaos of of anything
that is thrown at us that's like the
ideal client for me
when you say chaos what kind of chaos
could come up
I think that like
the entertainment industry
is unlike a lot of other
fields uh because how quickly it mutates
there's always
new opportunities
but at the same time there could be new
risks so would you think you know let's
say from the 90s may not work now or
would you just it just everything's
rapidly
changing which is why you know it's also
kind of fun because you're like who
knows what's happening next but it just
means you just have to keep your eye out
there and see what's happening and be
like tapped in to to these Innovations
and that's you know to me what the chaos
is it's like in that bleeds into your
day-to-day too so on a macro level
there's all these shifts but it creates
Ripple effects did you feel
you know immediately and that's what you
have to be okay with
you're not getting into this
business because you're like you want
something that's very like stagnant
you get into it because you want
something that could just be super
compelling all the time because you
don't know what's going to happen next
and to me that's why I'm excited about
my work
do you like to be kept guessing
sometimes it's not that I want to be
kept guessing is that like
I've always been interested in media and
Technology like I've always been
interested in movies how they're
distributed how they're monetized so for
me I love just seeing like
I love seeing this world shifting and
seeing new new like possibilities like
to when you see Netflix and suddenly you
watch like you know a limited series
that Queen's Gambit on you're like wow
like that's possible like I haven't seen
a limited series like that before so
like to me it's about getting inspired
like you know I'm very open to finding
inspiration as new projects get made and
new businesses advance and then you
could see like an opportunity like
podcasting podcasting is starting to
blow up and it's so much fun to also
manage some podcasters and work with
them and work on those unique deals that
are starting to surface for major
companies
so that's what gets me and it's the
inspiration around these new uh new
Innovations that's what gets me like you
know interested in the next you know the
next one
and you had a podcast yourself yeah I
had a podcast called Hollywood 2.0 and
it was basically a podcast that covered
the intersection of media and Technology
and we talked to everybody from like uh
people who create virtual reality people
created distribution companies digitally
and it was exciting to just see like
what the you know Trailblazers are doing
and did you notice I don't know what
year you started that by the way I don't
remember exactly when I started I did it
for a few years and you know before I
was a manager and it just was it was
also fun it was like
seeing it and then seeing how other
people are experiencing
the industry and and where it's going
because the people I talked to were the
ones that are always on the bleeding
edge of innovation
so somebody could be from like the
Sundance uh you know Innovation you know
Sundown studying virtual reality and
Innovation and that speaker could be
coming from that point of view so to me
it was fun to
um watch these businesses evolve and
some of them actually one of them got
acquired one of the this the founders
like sold a uh a podcast company so it
was really cool to see the acquisition
and see money move into the podcast
space and that was like the early sign
of the you know signals of things that
come so yeah I really enjoyed it in a
lot of ways I keep doing it like through
my work by seeing you know maybe a movie
that I have a client makes could also be
a TV show like how do you spin off a
film into TV and that's starting to
become like you start seeing that people
are thinking that way like you'll see a
show
um that will be starting as a movie and
like recently there was a great film
that's on Netflix called the hater and
that was
uh you know sold to HBO as a TV show
pitch so that's a something that's
really unique to me I'm like wow like
you could do that so that's why I got
inspired but it's like what if I got one
of my clients movies that sold it like
that kind of thing
always keeps me uh keeps me thinking
should a writer seek out a manager or
should they wait till the manager seeks
them out I think that like they should
seek out a manager for sure but I do
think that there's
effective ways to do that
for instance seeing in the roster is
there somebody that you have a personal
relationship to so you could go through
you know ideally like a friend who may
be wrapped by a manager uh that could be
helpful
sorry so you said a roster like so a
manager might have a you know like
multiple clients that
are that they work with you know and one
of them might be the friend of a writer
who's unrepped and then they just like
might just go to somebody in that you
know who that manager reps and a writer
or whoever and then just say hey you
know I'd love to get my work to your
manager could you make an introduction
so that's a way to do it
um another way to do it
is you basically
just go you know go through like just an
email you have an email Quarry you know
a letter where you just send it and I
think that they just need to be really
simple like hey my name is such and such
I have a science fiction script
um I would love for you to check it out
here's a log line
if you're interested I'm happy to sign
like a script release just uh no one
just wants to get exposed a bunch of
material legally so just saying hey I'm
open to sign that you know keep it
simple
that's great like that's all you know
that's a very simple email and ideally
you research the managers because like I
don't really work with a lot of like you
know like purely comedy clients like
it's just not my
you know it's on my wheelhouse and you
know sometimes people just will be like
you're a manager but they don't see that
I have a specific curation
so I think you really need to know who
you're contacting or else you're wasting
your time
and I think that like there doesn't need
to be a whole narrative to that email it
needs to be something that you could
just
pick up your iPhone and just read it and
go okay do I like this log line does
that interest me
you know because sometimes I get these
emails are super long
and I don't have a lot of bandwidth you
know so for me it's just like it's
almost like diminishing returns
on making it too wordy it's almost
better just to say
my concept is so hot like you're going
to want to read the script it's going to
be you're just gonna read it and you're
like tell me more
and that's enough but you know sometimes
you get too much information and you
know I think that it's not the the right
way to move forward because it's just as
confusing because you're like what did
this person want who are the it just
becomes more but if it's like here's an
idea
let's talk you know and I think that's
the the key to do is just keep it simple
what is a script release
like some type of like you know
paperwork that you know they signed that
so you know
you're not
you know connected to their script if
you somehow 10 years later have a you
know slightly similar project or it's
just like it's it's customary for almost
all managers
you know to have some level of
protection for being exposed to Newark
so it releases you of liability in case
they feel that there's another script
out there similar to their I guess I
mean it's just normal I mean whatever
you know any way to frame it I mean it's
just no one wants to like get a bunch of
scripts sent to them and then somehow is
there a connection to other materials
just keeps it simple it's just a
professional way
um when you're exposed to new work and
you know just smart for any manager to
not just get random you know emails of
scripts so you know you know someone's
not really familiar with the businesses
if they start by emailing you their
script they should always like be
clearly open to like signing that
release at what point should a writer
reevaluate whether they're ready to
approach a manager or an agent I don't
you know I think that like ideally they
have like a body of work that
you know speaks to their voice so let's
say they
you know write in the romantic comedy
genre if they have a few scripts that
really are like reflective of who they
are then why not you know I think um
they shouldn't
try out you know the different you know
steps to getting a rep I think it's
valuable now if someone's not really
clear on what they want to do
and they're still kind of discovering
what gets them excited and maybe they
should just kind of like have fun and
make things and then kind of find their
their voice later and there's no
pressure to have a rep you don't need
one as you know as a Creator you could
just do your own thing but I think it
it's it's valuable when you have a sense
of what kind of you know you know
Creator you want to be what genre you
want to work in or who do you want to
collaborate with so the more specific
you get about what you're passionate
about is probably a time where maybe a
rep could be valuable
how common is it for a manager to part
ways with their client I mean I think
it's like Case by case I don't think
there's like a frequency or a normal way
to do it or
you know where it's like more or less
given you know like the manager like
there's not like
I guess a way like a framework where you
could point to like this is what's
typical
but you know I just think that in
general like
you know people who are working together
on a regular basis
should have like you know they can't
always have a shared Vision that's not I
mean nobody you work with in any
profession is always completely aligned
but I think that it has to be in the in
a certain like level of communication
or there's a mutual respect and the
paths that you've embarked on
are um accepted and ex and they excite
you you and your collaborator versus a
huge Schism in the sense of you know
strategy so yeah I mean it's just case
to case you know I think you just have
to work with people
that get you excited and get you
passionate so I think that's the most
important part and whether or not
there's a departure or they're not I
mean that's fine you know you really
have One Life to Live you want to enjoy
who you work with
sure because there can be people that
are they're brilliant at what they do
and then maybe temperament-wise they're
not a match or vice versa there could be
people that as you said earlier you want
to hang with but maybe Talent level
they're not there yet yet you know I
think that like
you just want to work with people
that you believe in you know and and
they have to believe in you too so
they're that's a collab you know it's
the collaboration
and you know that there's a you know
there's going to be challenges you know
in all facets of the business but you're
fine with them you know like I said it's
all about adaptation so can you work
together as everything shifts and you
have to keep coming up with new ways to
find the win because that's what we want
to do we want to
push to go forward you want to keep
moving we want to keep progressing
and I think that's the goal is that the
people you're working with have that you
know the same vision
to lead to being a successful
filmmaker you know and I think that like
same with you as a manager you share the
success with your clients you know
something you feel the wins too
so I think that the question is
do your client and you
have a have that partnership that's
meaningful and if there is problems in
either of the person doesn't want to
work together that's fine you know they
could work with somebody else or vice
versa it's not a tragedy it's just you
have to work with people
that you find that a fulfilling
profession to be part of this team and
that's what that's what matters is that
at the end of the day you need to just
sell the project you know and you feel
good you like that you like what the
person's about you like what you you
really enjoy
the getting there it's not just that one
sale it's like the the communication was
in place you know you guys like how you
get excited about the same movies you
know so I think that you know it's fine
if relationships part because then maybe
there's a another rep who connects with
them in a better way so it's not about
disconnecting random people it's about
building successful teams
and it's great to have belief in people
but unfortunately in the real world
people will let you down and maybe they
don't try to maybe it's not intentional
but have you ever had to have a
conversation with someone that says you
know I need you to be more on point or
we had this meeting and you didn't show
up you don't have to give me specifics
as to who someone is but where they
weren't holding up their end of the
bargain
and you had to have quote The Talk
honestly no like I don't want to have
that talk I mean I think that you know
there is a period where you're talking
to a
potential client and you just have to be
honest like with them about how you like
to work and you know maybe you talk to
their collaborators about their
experience working with them and just
get a sense of like what's important you
know and
when you know what's important
to a collaborator and they know your
values I don't have issues about
performance so it's not like somebody's
like slipping is that we've already kind
of got through it in the initial like
introduction and uh and you know teaming
up
okay what if someone has some dry
periods in their life where they're not
creating anything
would you retain them as a client I mean
like everybody has to
work their own way like there isn't like
it's not a mechanical process it's not
like they're making widgets you know is
that it's deeply personal to tell a
story you know it's not something that
you could just you know turn into a
system where you could just do a paint
by numbers process and if you could it'd
probably be a terrible movie
um
if that's not what I want they might
have to take time you know so
when there's a collaborator and they're
like hey I need some distance to kind of
come up with an idea or you know the
work on a project
that's fine I have plenty of clients
that are in the mix of something new so
the only area where that could be
problematic and I haven't dealt with
that personally but if somebody is hired
to do a job
and then they can't execute on it that's
where that becomes a problem not when
they need time to you know write a new
spec it's when there's a contract sign
and you know money has exchanged hands
and somebody's like paralyzed that could
be
an issue for sure like but it's not a to
me it's not a big deal if
a Storyteller needs to sit back and like
watch movies like live a little bit run
around do different things and then just
lock in
to
a vision for a project like uh my
brother's a filmmaker and I see him
sometimes like he'll have to walk into a
museum or he'll do something or he'll go
somewhere and then he'll get his mind
activated so I've seen it growing up and
my dad is also an author he's written
some historical uh you know novels he
needs to just kind of like get that
Groove so it's fine to me I don't have
an expectation that a person has to
constantly be churning out material
uh they whatever they need to get you
know the ideas you know
building you know and moving forward is
fine with me
but if someone has an advance on a book
and
they have a contractual obligation to
turn in some type of pages at a certain
time and they haven't
you've never had to deal with no and
then you're calling and there's no
return calls and you know you never had
to
face that no like the when the when the
contract is signed I've had clients just
get to work you know it's not precious
at all they're just do their job and I
know sometimes like
you'll see um you know in movies this
like you know author who's like you know
totally out to lunch and not in the game
at all and then their agents calling or
whatever you know but like for Pages no
I haven't dealt with that they're you
know they're working on a project or
professionals and they're delivering uh
you know on time okay so you haven't had
any scenes of like factotum or Barfly
where you have to go and
pull someone out of the corner bar and
get them in front of the typewriter no
not at all like it's not that you know
unfortunately it's not that exotic it's
not like a movie it's just kind of like
this do their thing like if you're
hiring somebody in any profession good
okay sounds like you have a good
intuition as to who you take on so yeah
definitely
how do you know if a writer is talented
I can only speak to
what gets me
you know super interested in them and
ultimately you know like just kind of
their General
you know portfolio what they've written
you know who they worked with but
there's something about the writing
that cuts through
all the Clutter
and that's the that's the project
that I want to support and that's the
you know Storyteller that I want to get
behind
because it's somebody that like writes
something that just like freezes time
and nothing else matters you know your
phone is buzzing every day and you get
just you know meaningless messages and
you know on social media you'll get like
little updates that somebody likes
something or whatever but look there's
not nothing's that big of a deal but the
writing to me is truly powerful
all those insignificant distractions
just kind of like
uh start to dim and move into the
background and the only thing that's
important
is uh the characters that they created
what's your process for evaluating a
writer's skill level
when you think about nothing but
the the control they have on you like a
great writer like well
um almost like the work will just like
take you away from every Everything uh
that doesn't matter that's not the work
so
I look at like you know how distracted
you know the average person is right now
and if if you're a really good writer
you could just
pull them away from
that life where everything is like a 24
second news cycle and nothing really
matters uh but you you know you get that
dopamine hit anytime you check your
phone
and somebody who could really take you
out of that
and make you really you know give a
about
these
you know characters that that they came
out that came out of their mind and that
is more important
to you than um
those distractions and you live in that
world you know for a while that's that's
when you know that the person
you know has the chops
how do you know they if they don't have
the chops maybe not yet well there's a I
would say there's a spectrum of like
qualities that you could look at uh you
know a potential client
um there's somebody that you could read
the first 10 pages
and you know you could just say maybe
it's just not for you you know maybe
just like the tone you know maybe it's
too quirky you like things a little bit
more grounded so that's not necessarily
a talent thing right but then there's
something that you see that could be
totally incompetent
like it's just bad writing and it's not
about your taste because I know what I
like and I know when there's really
talented uh you know writers working in
a space that I'm not interested in
it doesn't mean they're bad it's just
not something they that I'm passionate
about but I think you can know pretty
quickly if
it's a taste thing or is it
um they just need a lot more uh
experience and they're just you know
their work is rough
I think you'd said on the final draft
podcast which was excellent by the way
your interview with them that there was
a writer that was doing something about
um these kids that were part of this
magazine sales thing across the country
and they would travel together and these
were like they were it was almost like a
group home but like a traveling yeah you
know some of these kids that maybe were
unfortunately Wards of the court or
something and can you talk about that so
who was that writer I don't remember
where I got that idea 100 I just knew
that there might have been like a story
I think about these uh traveling
magazine sales people that were young
like you know basically teenagers
running around peddling these
subscriptions
and they were kind of like a ragtag
group of individuals and they had an
interesting life to you know so for me
like
I don't like using the term like oh it's
just like oh it's a high concept idea I
mean it's fine you know but I almost
look at it like tell me an idea that
when you tell when I hear about it I
want to know more that's I think that's
the test and not have some weird metric
for it but like if someone tells me
about
a vigilante that went around the you
know the what you know like the
beginning of America and fought like
criminals and they were you know
mysterious and they were never found and
we don't know who it could have been I'd
be like oh I like Vigilantes I love
mystery so like there's obviously a
certain
boxes that could be checked for what I
would find an interesting idea that may
not always work with other people so
that's what I'm saying there's not a
there's not a science to what is a
compelling concept
um but I can know what it gets me
interested and and when you look at like
The Blacklist or the blood list those
log lines are really cool like you know
these are great these are great writers
and they have ideas that want makes you
want to know more
you know that's what it is it's not
because it's like a gimmick or something
it's because there's something
interesting there
how do you know if a writer is capable
of writing at a professional level if
they move you emotionally
um because it's about emotions it's
about making people feel something
and there's writers that can write to
the Forum perfectly and you read it it's
fine
but it doesn't make you feel anything
in the same way like I listen to music
almost like a drug like I'll listen to
music that will get me hyped I'll get
listen to music that will mellow me like
it moves you you could use
uh this you know the audio experience to
change your state of mind
movies in my opinion could do the same
way there's movies that will that get
you hyped and Disturbed movies that will
like make you kind of like have comfort
food they have qualities to them and I
think that the key to know if a writer
is somebody that you want to work with
is you are being affected it's changing
our state of mind
in a in a powerful way
and if it's just the script and you read
it and it's totally derivative
you just feel like it's like a bad cover
band
like who know who wants to watch the
the cover band you want to watch kids
play you know or whatever it is you want
to see the ideally you want to see the
the purest form of that vision
and and when I speak to the sense of a
cover band is you want somebody's
authentic voice and that's what you're
getting you want the purest version of
who they are
and that's going to get you
really into their work if those hooks
get in you because you're feeling
someone is very unique at speaking to
you through the work and changing your
emotional you know levels you know and
that's what art does it affects you so I
think for me to gauge whether or not
someone's professional is like am I
getting excited am I getting scared am I
Disturbed like like is it is it
influencing me
and if it's not maybe I don't like the
genre or whatever or the tone that's
fine or maybe the writer needs to do
another few rewrites to really refine
you know their vision
so are there are there writers that are
versions of cover bands I mean sometimes
I've heard some amazing cover bands by
the way but yes sometimes it's it's a
watered-down version of your favorite
artist but are there are there cover
band writers
I don't know if there's exactly like I
would say purely a cover band writer and
like there are awesome cover bands like
don't get me wrong I mean there's some
that really have their own you know take
on something or kind of almost
supernaturally capture the essence
of
a musician that she loved which is also
really cool I'm just saying that you
know maybe there's like a version of a
cover band
that feels kind of hacky you know that
doesn't hit all the beads doesn't have
that
you know excitement that intangible
quality that made you fall in love
with a band they're they're good enough
right and you're like okay
I've seen that before it's so why am I
seeing it like this it feels like the
the watered down version
that's different there are writers that
are very nostalgic and they in a lot of
ways they sample openly
stirring qualities that you might like
from a movie from the 80s and but they
make it their own
you know they're not just they're not
like stealing from anything they're
extracting the essence of it and then
you're seeing something uh you're seeing
a point of view so I guess that's what I
would say is the point of view maybe not
a point of view on
let's say like this is the point of view
on the theme that's a universal theme
and they talk about it it can be a point
of view on a genre
so maybe they're talking about slashers
but
it's a really interesting hot take it's
in the same way you think of like a
great film critic could talk about a
movie and really make you think about it
and really feel something different
about the movie
a writer that could have these
perspectives I won't call a cover band I
would say they're offering insight
into storytelling and maybe in a meta
quality or something that's really
fascinating I'm talking about what I'm
talking about here is somebody is
uninspired that is not offering anything
new to the intellectually or maybe
emotionally then it's just why do we
need another X
okay so it's like a cover band if you
said kiss so it's like you've gone to a
bar and they're playing Detroit Rock
City but it's like slow and it's
it's kind of distorted and you're like
almost but not quite like oh this almost
hurts my ears so it's the same thing a
writer is trying to emulate let's say JK
Rowling and they're trying but it's it's
like no I see what they're trying to do
and they're speed they're trying to
emulate her voice they're emulating it
without offering A New Perspective
you know because there are because in a
lot of ways like you know Stern certain
creators are almost like like I was
saying like critics is they're using
their work to almost be
uh you know to comment on
a type of character or type of genre and
that actually to me is actually really
interesting mine's like the my criticism
of a certain type of writer is when
they're not bringing anything new to the
table
the perspective is is not defined and
then they're just Recycling and it
doesn't and you really don't get
anything out of it so yeah that's that's
what I'm talking about so yeah like
there's amazing cover bands but I'm
talking about the cover band where
you're like why don't I just watch the
actual band like that's the one not
someone that goes oh my God I thought I
was there or you know like who am I
who's on stage or wow this is a crazy
subversion of the song like the Pixies
have had like a million covers of their
big song you know where's my mind but
the good cover is really take you
somewhere different okay so it kind of
like almost like Prague Rock of
something that wasn't meant to be that
way or it captures it beautifully like
I'm open to those things but I'm talking
about the end of the day the type of
script that when I'm done reading I
don't get anything emotionally or
intellectually
new from my Baseline experience
how does the writer know that they are
the original writer
this is their voice they have to serve
their perspective in the same way as a
manager I have to be honest to myself
you know what you know material gets me
you know into the game and gets me you
know ready to like go out and start
selling and and pushing projects is I
have to believe in it you know has to be
real to me
in a lot of ways it has to be real to
them you know when you see a lot of
filmmakers starting out like in the
early stages like somebody might come
out of film school and they may look to
a director that they love and almost do
their own version of a cover band
because they're just trying to learn the
technology they're learning the the
craft but then as they mature they
Advance beyond that and then they start
cultivating a voice they may have
certain genetic you know quality the
genetics of their favorite filmmakers
but it's also a new statement they're
making in the space that is only theirs
because I think we can all think that
we're original you know like but if I
let's say I'm always reading Joyce Carol
Oates novels that I'm going to probably
allow that to seep into my writing style
and maybe not even be aware of it so how
do I know
is it from feedback from outside sources
is that the only way we really know if
we're being authentic
I think that like it's fine if somebody
goes
I'm a Alfred Hitchcock Super Fan and
that's going to inspire my work
but it's where we go from there like I
think some people you know could look at
you know the amount of filmmakers that
that one you know auteur just influenced
and there's just so many countless you
know
students of this director but it's what
they do with it why is it interesting
you know and
the only way to know how your work
resonates is how people read it so like
maybe somebody could write something
that's in the the vein of another
creator
but what they end up making is still
impactful
so you're measuring impact not some type
of purity test of originality
is you give someone your script
they get moved emotionally and
intellectually
that's that's what the goal is so yeah I
don't want to make it so like I'm
evaluating does it have to be perfectly
original or whatever that means I don't
know if that even means anything I'm
talking about what are do people
love the experience does it experience
is it is it memorable uh that's what
matters I don't want to get into like
that director sampled this and that like
to me it's like I don't care I like I
like collage artists I like artists that
take things I like uh producers that
produce music and they sample like other
artists and they make something
interesting but they have to make
something interesting I think that's
what I'm evaluating is
the experiential quality not whether or
not they you know were clearly inspired
by somebody else that's not uh the
metric
do you have an example of maybe a film
you watched in college where it just
it changed you somehow
For Better or Worse
I don't think like any movie like it's
like a that I was actually changed but I
do see I do see movies that I just get
excited by like and I don't know if
there was like some you know spiritual
experience where I was like whoa
Everything's changed but
I do really love
um certain movies by John Waters or
Tarantino or like Takeshi katano like I
see what they could do or you know
Elaine may like there's people making
things and they you know like I don't
know how they did that it just blew my
mind I mean it's almost like if you're
like you know a food critic and you go
to some restaurant and you bite into
something and you're like whoa what just
happened here you know like there's
something like something's going on I
can't put a finger on it but it's really
working
so I don't think there's this one thing
I think it's more of like a mix of a lot
of different experiences but I think I
think when you're done with it you're
like I want to watch every movie they
made like I want to watch
whatever they have next or if they're
not alive I just want to move through
their entire like library and check out
what they have going on so to me that
that's how I feel it's just you get
excited it's excitement that's what
we're measuring or not it's not
it's not like we pull out our measuring
stick and we go we're measuring the
perfect exact thing we need it's like
he's like you know when you say holy
that is great and it's so good you
want to tell everybody about it that's
how you know it matters is that you want
to share it with somebody that's why
that's why I think it's kind of like
when you want to push a movie on
somebody else it's not just like
casually talk about a movie like there's
a movie um called pill flowers Yakuza
crime film old black and white film it's
so good I have influenced like five of
my friends to watch it so when you're
getting other people to get into
whatever you're into that's how you know
it worked obviously but like that's how
I know that a film has deeply resonated
is that I'm now representing the movie
as a super fan does it have subtitles
yes oh so it's a Japanese film
what year is it from not sure it was
like something that like I found and
then I just started
pushing to people who I think would like
it so then I start like recommending it
and telling everyone I know about it so
that's how I look at it is that I don't
I don't have one special experience but
I just know the physic the actual events
that take place in my mind when I see a
movie like that or I see or a specific I
could point to a filmmaker where I'm
like that person's doing something
really exciting and then I just you know
for the rest of my life I'm I'm pushing
that filmmaker or their movie on anyone
in the airshot
can you give us an example of how you
helped one of your writers sell their
scripts and get a movie made so yeah I
have a project that
I sold and we basically worked on
developing
the pitch together and we brought
together to write producers and team and
made attachments and we had a pitch on
Zoom which made it very challenging
because this was during the pandemic so
this was a project to just like which
made it crazy is we sold a movie during
a like dystopian you know event like
where it we can't leave our our place so
we prepped it on zoom and it was
extremely like challenging because you
know a lot of the process of selling an
idea is very physical you're in a room
together and
it's it's CR it's something that you
have to have a presence but when you're
on a laptop like Max Headroom and you're
just like a floating ahead
it makes it infinitely more difficult
to sell a project so you know we had a
tough situation you know how do we make
something really good because we had you
know a studio Executives that were going
to be on a zoom call so we decided that
you know the pitch that we just make
20 minutes make it just the best 20
minutes possible
because you know a certain point the
tension span of it most people starts
diminishing especially on a screen if
you're in the physical world it's so
much easier to just like be compelling
and have that kind of like energy that
everyone feeds from but when you're
looking at like you know your laptop
it's a completely different so we
decided that you know making it shorter
was better and the goal was
in the questions and answers we'd be
able to activate more interest and get
more information so we shortened this
pitch way smaller than we'd ever do in a
normal event would make it much longer
if we're in in that room so we shorten
it really practice it we ran the pitch
through multiple people we actually had
and I think some people don't get it is
that like pitching is like writing you
have to iterate like I think some people
think you just show up and Pitch but
actually pitching is kind of uh when you
think of like a performer like a
comedian they might even record their
sets just to hear do they hit all the
Beats is it does it really resonate or a
musician could perform at a show and
then see people and really get a sense
of does that set work
so we had the writer go through all
these cycles of prepping of different
types of people because we didn't know
the energy that was going to be given in
that and ultimately through defining the
the size of the pitch prepping to
multiple people
during this horrible event that we were
living everybody was living in and we
were able to
sell a movie
um despite those challenges and it
resonated perfectly with the buyers so I
mean that is an event that like
collectively we weren't looking at the
pitch as such something that's ready
made and I think that's a problem with a
lot of filmmakers they're like yeah just
get ready for the pitch but a pitch you
should even to me look at like a like a
script you get the script you kind of
come out the ID and you just refine it
and you iterate and you just keep making
it better and better a pitch should be
the same way you should be able to try
it on different people Workshop it see
where people are at and don't just pitch
people that are already working on it
like if you're just oh I just talked to
my collaborator you should get
individuals who are new to what you're
talking about and they should have notes
for you what ideas resonated do you rush
by Exposition how did it develop and
really just making sure that the timing
is right
and
you know
um is it exciting do you get all the
information across and we really had
this criteria and ultimately it was
successful because we were taking that
seriously
I have a TV pitch going out soon we're
doing the same thing
um because right now we're still you
know getting past you know this horrible
situation to ultimately be in the real
world but I think that was the valuable
you know
you know experience was taking that part
of the equation as seriously as writing
that amazing script because if it's just
the pitch it's about trust why should we
trust you to be the one that gets hired
to you know write something and you need
to put that work in because the person
that you're pitching to if they're
valuable
if they're like high you know High
powerful you know executive on the top
of a major company they don't have a lot
of time
so you can't just kind of Waltz in and
throw ideas around you have to like
really just
test your presentation to the point
where it's fantastic it doesn't matter
how long you've done it too like it's
not just doing it once maybe you do 10
times maybe you do it more but it has to
be to the point where a new person who's
never heard of this project
sees it and if it's done on Zoom if
that's where the situation is it's fine
you move them you get them to go this is
something that I want to get behind and
that's uh what was successful you know I
sold multiple projects so I think that
you have to when you sell these new you
know films or TV shows you want to make
sure that the energy that of your idea
is transferring and the information is
to people who don't have the same level
of relationship that you do
and it could have been harder uh during
the during that time to get make this
work because it was so unnatural to
everybody involved but once we were okay
with it we're like this is our our frame
a screen this is the attention span we
designed it to the user to the to the
individual who has the power to say yes
and that's why I was successful and
that's my my role in this project was
making sure that the pitch was ready for
Showtime
do you have the writer film themselves
and then you critique it or they even
watch themselves back to see how are
they coming across in the pitch
them look at themselves on video but
what I do is I firm it up with them and
then I just recommend them just testing
it on you know people they respect
so get to the right length
engine is hitting those beats over and
over again
it's almost like you want to make it
feel like it's natural
but it's not it's designed you know when
you do Assurant expression or you know
when you pause they're going to lean in
it's so designed
that you're kind of taking them on a on
a journey but you know where the tracks
are
do you think most writers take too long
to get to the point because by Nature
they love writing they love
communicating
and they need to shorten their message
I think there's now one
you know experience I've had on the on
the pitching front
but I do think that
it's very important and that the people
that you want to bring on as
stakeholders in your
in your in your movie or your TV show
they have a little window and you have
to get them
to care because they might not they
might not start caring you have to take
them from potentially apathy to really
being invested and that's the journey
you have to take now take them on in
it's really there's no one approach and
there's no one writer with a certain
temperament it's all across the board
but the more you cycle through feedback
and really perfect it you have a better
chance of resonating with the right
people
so a great writer and a great pitch
turns apathetic people into sitting up
straight in their chair
I mean they may not give you any tells
because an individual might just be like
this the whole time so you might not
know it's not to be totally clear it's
not they're gonna Applause or anything
like a big Applause at the at the end of
it they might give you a poker face
okay because maybe they don't want to
give you anything during this
time frame
because when you sell something
they're spending money you know and
maybe it's maybe it's an investor maybe
it's someone who you know has a fund or
maybe they know someone of money whoever
it is someone's taking a risk
so you might not get
like any tells
that it's resonating you might just get
a very apathetic expression
but
if they have all the information they
need
to make a decision
once it's over
behind closed doors they might say it
was pretty cool but they may not give
that to you during that time because
they might lose power they have
more of ability to really think it
through if there's a wall
that's up over here
because then they could
think about it they could talk to
collaborators and really discuss the
opportunity doesn't matter if they have
a reaction or not you know you've tested
it on all the right you know individuals
that give you feedback so regardless of
the emotional reaction of who's
listening at the end of the day is you
know you're ready that's what matters
almost Envision yourself
at like a live poker you're watching
live poker on TV and you see these
people with the Dark Shades and and the
cat pulled down and almost Envision
yourself pitching in front of them and
you know there's going to be no reaction
no they're not even going to scratch
their nose to give away some kind of
discomfort or nervousness absolutely but
there could be another type of you know
potential buyer who talks all the time
so you just want to be able to test your
pitch out on
all sorts of personalities if you don't
know who you're pitching is it just
going to be like a quiet you know room
that has low energy
that could be the case or somebody keeps
cutting you off
you have to be ready and flexible to get
your message out
in a confident professional way
so there could be high energy hyper
almost like a caged animal type of a
pitch not on the writer's part but of
the of the person being pitched you just
don't know who they are right I mean
it's just like anybody you know we all
have different personalities
if you don't know who you're pitching
you could be ready for any type of
energy
you pull them in
and they really feel something
you might know you might not know it
doesn't matter you just need to know
you're ready for it
with this call the zoom pitch that
you're talking about how many people
were on the call and then what was the
project purchased after the zoom call
like immediately after I think it was
might have been
five or six I don't really completely
remember you know everybody that was on
it but it was about it I feel it was
about five or six and it wasn't bought
on the call
um there was like you know we heard
later you know typically I haven't
experienced anything that just happens
in the moment where somebody would
commit to
so that it typically has a bit of a
delay where people have to regroup
like do you know how much like did you
hear maybe a month later a week later
I think it was a
I think it was about a week or so okay
so you didn't lose too much sleep but no
you were you were waiting and then once
do you get do you get an email that says
it's a go we're having people draw up
contracts or do they have more questions
there were there really weren't any more
questions
on this event it wasn't they didn't
continue
to like pull information from the
players involved in this project it was
established on that one pitch
oh okay so then the email was basically
we love it it's a green light yeah the
phone call was like that yeah oh okay
nice
nice how long was the final curated
pitch are you talking about the the
pitch that this include the Q a
afterwards oh so so there's the pitch
and then the five people and there's a q
a
um well some people on the who are being
pitched have some questions but it
wasn't a lot I would say in in total I
think that
this ex this one for about
30 minutes
like because what happens also too
it starts with a little bit of like you
know small talk
so first is a small talk then there's a
pitch and then there's like a little
questions and answers
that was it so it was about half an hour
and you know this is a silly question
but in the time of sensitivity what is
acceptable small talk because you could
really say the wrong thing and you think
you're joking and you're just being
sarcastic whatever what is an acceptable
realm of small talk and and how should a
writer behave
just like any other job that the writer
might have had what is an expectation if
you
worked
in an office or if you're a student in
college it's what you know
you would uh do in these settings that
you just have to hold a you know a
serious
presentation of yourself it's not a a
space to be
acting you know
so out of like you know out of that
frame because there's an expectation
that when you're in this kind of room is
that they're taking a risk on you
um when you're trying to get somebody
to invest in you
and there's money on the line
why don't you go in their shoes How do
they
if you're them what kind of person would
you want to
risk a fortune on
you know and that should you know
establish
how you behave is you just have to have
empathy for them and if you do then you
know how you initially present yourself
will be
the right professional face
well there's different cultures in
different workplaces I've worked in
somewhere
you know nothing but the facts don't
don't refer to anything that's not work
related whereas there's others where
people shared personal details of their
life and that was the norm you know it's
probably too far on the Spectrum but
just knowing like reading the room like
going in because some people might have
a little bit of more of a looser style
but you don't want to overstep that
bound and that's an easy line to cross
especially these days
well I mean this is most likely
a new relationship uh in when I'm
talking about if you don't know
what their approach
to their business is is that you might
not know them that well or know them at
all
if they're a stranger then more of a
neutral approach makes sense because you
got the empathy that if this investor is
going to finance your film
you could come out with more of a
baseline because you don't know them and
you don't have to perfectly match their
energy but you have to be respectful of
what kind of dynamic they're going to
get into if they're a green light or
movie
so I think the key is not leading over
assumptions and just
imagining what it would be like to be
seen down in the other chair and having
to take a major risk on someone you
don't know or we barely know in the
terms of this online pitch during the
pandemic that we're referring to was
this an existing relationship or did you
start this during did you reach out to
this person during the pandemic
I I'd say that
some parties had a relationship with the
buyers some didn't it was a mix
when you're working with a writer can
you explain how you reverse engineer
their path forward so in some situations
I like to think about where I want to be
and I start there
and then I walk backwards so you're
thinking
what kind of producer or director or
actor is he like to collaborate with
you know what are your references to
other movies that are in the space
so you might be thinking
the expectation of the fans of a genre
you might be thinking
the scope of a movie
for example there are horror films that
are made for a hundred thousand dollars
some of them are made for a few million
and then there's bigger budget ones that
are mid-range which are in a whole other
category
so
I want to know what model are we working
in the last thing you'd want to do is
get a script that's unproducible
where the budget's just too big for the
genre typically
and
it's not going to work you want to be
able to have a general sense of in a
perfect scenario
who's on board to produce it direct it
act in it Finance it is it from private
financiers is it from a studio or is it
streamer good to back it like get a
general sense I mean obviously these
things could be flexible
so I'm not saying being stuck on it
but knowing what
you're fulfilling a demand
you're not creating a demand
and I think that's important uh so on a
on this kind of knowing where you where
you fit in
another party you also want to think
about is
what is it about this concept that makes
it unique
now I don't mean like making something
that's so like esoteric and weird that
it's Unique because it's just strange I
mean like if we've seen
a certain kind of bank heist film
what is it about it that's familiar and
what about it is a new way in and I
could talk about tonally
conceptually the type of characters are
in it the plot there's all sorts of room
to make it new
so it's that Balancing Act
and if there's not enough unique
elements
in the story
you know my worry sometimes is Who's
Gonna Want It
it just feels kind of what's out there
and that's a problem you're gonna put
all that work into writing it yet
there's 10 other movies like it that
just came out
so ideally I want to know the business
model like how does this work who would
want to be part of this collaboration
potentially and then on a creative level
what makes this special
and
once we have achieved that and we know
there's space
then it works like I kind of look at
like there's a big white board okay and
the board has things already on it like
Mark marked it up but there's a space on
that board where your movie fit or TV
show fits in
and the key is making sure the ideas
feel that there's some room for it it's
not redundant and it's not just not
tenable and it's in the business model
so that really affects how I think about
potential Concepts to pursue developing
into Scripts
have you ever had a client or potential
client say are you gonna make this my
career like if I work with you and sign
with you
can I be guaranteed by within this
amount of time this will be my career
I'll be a working screenwriter podcaster
producer
no
I have never experienced that
approach I mean I'm sure some people
have it and it's fine
but typically I'm dealing with somebody
who's understands
the complexities of the industry
so someone who would ask those questions
that's that's a big that's a newbie
that's an amateur
I don't know I mean you know that end of
it that individual has the right to ask
any questions to a potential manager
um I haven't encountered that and I
don't know if that means they're a
newbie I mean you know anybody
could
you know address their concerns or their
ambition
with the Reps that they want to bring in
to their team it's totally fine but I
just haven't encountered somebody who
would put that on the table would you
say a lot of writers naturally think
this way in terms of reverse engineering
their path
so maybe they don't know how things are
going to turn out for them but they want
to try to see okay this is where I want
to be this is the level I want to be
working at with these type of players
now how do I get there I think every
client has their own approach I think
as a manager you want to think about
how a project
can go on a journey to it becomes a you
know a very high quality
you know experience once it's produced
that it's successful not just because it
got made
critically and it has an incredible
return on the investment of who buys
into it that's important to me and I
can't lose sight of the business
when I look at you know any project any
ideas that we just started discussing
now will writer have the the mindset to
reverse engineer
their script Maybe
Maybe not maybe there's a theme they
want to explore
and that's totally fine I don't think
there is one way
to bring something to life
you know I think that whatever their
whatever they're prioritizing in the
Inception of the idea and then how it
develops so it's all across the board
what do you say to the writer who says I
just do writing I don't do anything else
I know my story is going to resonate
there's an emotional connection with the
protagonist find someone else to produce
it and Market it and do all the heavy
lifting but I just wrote it and that's
all I need to do well it's fine there's
plenty of producers out there who love
collaborating with great writers
I mean it's a personal choice if
somebody wants to be a hyphenite
it's it's something that if that's what
matters to them
then they should make that their focus
if if a client
just wants to write Scripts
that should be their focus you know I
don't want to do anything but manage and
produce
I don't want to do any other capacity in
this industry and that's my choice so I
want to expect a writer to have to act
in it or direct it or produce or do
anything beyond
sitting down and you know working on
developing new material
so you wouldn't be opposed to that if
you had a potential client that said I
have things that I write I know they're
excellent that's all I do I don't do
windows I just I just write that's all I
do I mean that's totally fine I I don't
value that type of client
more or less than somebody
who wants to take on additional you know
you know responsibilities
you think it shows an attitude of being
inflexible or they just do one thing and
they don't want to dilute what they do
I don't see any inflexibility at all
there's an entire Union the wga that
protects writers
because this is a community that in a
lot of ways you know they build they're
like this they build so much
incredible you know stories and they are
part of this industry in in the most
meaningful way there's no reason why a
writer
has to direct it's it's you know it's a
choice my brother
is a writer who ultimately you know he
was he that's what got him into the a
lot of into the game and now he's
directing and then you start he's also
producing and he does that and I have
friends or actors who are also writers I
mean
you know in the same way uh Mia you know
as a manager like there's something
compelling
about working with Incredible
storytellers and that
uh is my passion and I that's why I you
know every day I I get up and look
forward to the next you know project and
the next pitch or I get it keeps keeps
me moving you know that's that energy
that I get from my work because it's so
well suited for me in the same way a
writer if that process
excites them there's no reason to do
anything else
so you can respect that someone who
knows what they're great at and they
know where their skills lie and they're
not going to deviate from that just so
that they can get a project moved along
or they if they're also you're okay with
people being as you say a
multi-hyphenate yeah I mean it's it's a
spectrum I mean there's people who do
everything and it's just incredible what
they they have so many hats but it's not
for everybody and I totally respect that
I don't look at it negatively if
somebody
really wants to just be a writer because
it's hard to to have that as their
singular Focus so that doesn't mean that
it's that much easier
it comes with a lot of challenges to be
successful so
there's no expectation that somebody has
to direct and it doesn't also mean that
if you're just a writer
you're not being pragmatic because if
you write incredible work you might find
a director that you love working with
and now you have a partner
and that director might not want to
write so that's like a perfect fit
what are those challenges you said there
are challenges that come with being
successful well you start with a blank
page
that's hard you know you have to build a
reality out of nothing
and there might be an incredible
director who doesn't want to write a
script
but you see their music videos or their
short films
and you think they have the right tone
so then you go why don't we work
together you don't want it right you
just want to direct and
my my passion is writing scripts
and then you team up and you make
something really exciting
so you want your client or potential
clients to be comfortable in what they
do and their skill set and you don't try
to push them to do more
if that's not within them
it's just what they're passionate about
I have clients that
create IP and they love writing Comics
or making podcasts
that's all they want to do they don't
want to write Scripts
that's fine
because they're making something that
really
emotionally moved me I don't need
anything beyond what they already do
they they're already successful
being able to make
you know pieces of like art
that are meaningful
to Their audience and they get excited
about them and that's hard that's not
easy so changing
the changing them into hyphenites is
really just they're about their own
personal interests and I can Empower
somebody who wants to expand new
responsibilities
and support that
but at the same time it has to be a
natural progression of what they want to
do
I have something I would love feedback
on it's a mashup time travel slash
horror genre film
our protagonist is Seth
and he has created a time travel app
which he calls the time me up Scotty
okay so he's courting investors and
hoping to launch the app but before he
has like this big investor meeting he
you know gets comfortable on a Friday
night has a bunch of beers and he starts
playing with the app and accidentally
his own app which he it's his own
creation transports him
to Salem Massachusetts in the year 1692.
he finds himself
in this time travel that's gone through
in a Cell awaiting trial having been
accused of throwing his Specter as
witnessed by disgruntled villagers
meaning that he's his Witnesses Saw His
Image somewhere else essentially
accusing him of witchcraft
and the horror comes as he cannot prove
his innocence and he's set to be crushed
to death as punishment
so can you tell me your feelings on my
pitch
I think it's kind of cool
um I like it because
it kind of encapsulates
what's scary about the past
is that you can't reason with people
that have a completely different frame I
imagine I mean I've never time traveled
so I can't speak to that but I just
think that it's interesting that what
makes it scary is that it's an
individual
who
is now living in this reality
where
there's no reference point for anybody
else but himself and it's taking that
time travel
genre and then really making it kind of
like a horror movie in the sense of that
it's kind of like the fish out of water
but done in a way where there's real
threats and now you have to deal with
these threats
and I think that is what makes it
interesting so conceptually I think
there's a lot there but the device to
get
to where it's really getting good
I think that might need a little bit of
work
because I that it seems a little bit
like
there might be more of a streamlined way
so you have a device
that brings you into that time period
but once you're there I'm really curious
about what happens next
oh I have a little bit of backup but
that was on what happens but that was my
initial pitch so
if would that happen then if I were to
pitch let's say some some individuals
whether it's Zoom or in person would
they then those are some of the notes
possibly they would have what happens
next or I wonder if the frame is
you're talking to a manager for
potential representation and there's
like a networking event and you're just
saying hey I got an idea I was just
curious what's the dynamic here then
I'll be able to offer more specific
feedback okay great so we can take that
scenario first and then we could take
another one where I'm pitching let's say
producers so if I'm at a networking
event and I've I've met a manager and I
tell them my idea
what would the feedback do you think be
I think it's really gonna depend on
the manager's sensibilities so I mean
you know who knows they might love it or
they might hate it you know
so it depends on whether they think they
would want to take on
me as a client or whoever's pitching
this idea and if they like this idea
I don't know if it's about like did
Emily want to take on a potential client
but they might want you to
sign a release for that script and send
over
that material so they can evaluate it
okay good to know and then I if I'm
pitching a group of let's say five
producers and they've got their poker
Champion face on their Shades and their
and their hat and I can't tell what
they're thinking they're emotionless
um what would be some possible follow-up
in the Q a
well it depends I mean if it's pitching
five producers that feels like it might
be like a networking event that was
designed to expose new writers to
producers so I imagine that they'll be
respectful and they might have questions
and just kind of have a dialogue it may
be different
than if you are working with those
producers and then pitching like a
financier
so the producers may be more
animated and more more verbal and
engaged because it's not about you
pitching somebody that's just going to
press a button and get your movie made
they're going to first see if you're
somebody that they might want to
collaborate with and just kind of have
like a back and forth
because to get a movie made is a it
takes a long time typically so they just
want to know if they if that you're on
the same page and they like the idea and
then they also might request the script
too
what would be some potential questions a
financier might ask
if I pitch this idea I don't think that
like
they're gonna just give you a quick
answer
more likely that
they're gonna have a director pitch the
project and lead the pitch with a
producer so a writer
at the point where a financier is
involved I may not say all the time but
once a Project's mature enough for that
to be
the case a lot of times the director is
kind of really driving the pitches to
potential financiers
and what if I'm pitching a production
company
so I'm pitching them to sell my script
this idea to them I mean we're talking
about like let's say an environment
where it's like a networking event that
some script organization put on and
you're pitching a production company
I mean
you're basically telling them
the log line
in a short period of time what you know
and when you think about the log line
you're thinking about
why is this differentiating it uh for
this project from others so they you're
basically trying to sell them a trailer
to make them want to read the script so
that's kind of the goal is that you're
just saying hey got a really exciting
project
it's a time travel horror film what if
somebody from our time was stuck
in you know the age of witches and you
know when they're doing the Witch Hunt
what kind of scary things could happen
during that you know and then that's it
like you just give them a little pitch
less is more if the pitch goes on too
long and you lose their attention you
just really want to know what the hook
is
and then punctuate that and let them ask
questions your goal is to activate their
imagination
not the filibuster for like a long time
about all these ideas you really want to
make sure that it's a conversation
ultimately and not a monologue
so then they say thank you very much
hopefully they validate my parking they
show me out the door I sit in traffic
for two hours and I wonder did they like
it I think I saw one of their eyebrows
raised when I said this one thing I
think they liked it or I could tell this
one guy he had his lips person is his
hands cry you know his he was
the hands crossed a bunch against his
chest and he didn't like it and I'm a
I'm a done deal I'm finished in this
town I'm I mean you know there's I'm
going home you know they like it if they
asked
for
you know your email so their assistant
can email a script release I mean okay
you know it's not about reading up poker
face at that point it's pretty binary
immediately do they want to read it
and I don't know what the in this
fictional script event what the dynamic
is and how it's you know ran but sure
most likely if you
pitch to these
participants and they're excited about
it
they're going to get you to most likely
write a uh right right on the release
that they get through maybe themselves
or their assistant and then you send
them the script I mean that's really
what it is and then if they love it then
they will want to work with you and that
might be an option agreement
or a shopping agreement
and
some you know lock in the material and
ideally pay you some money and then
bring on the director and the actor so
like it's really the starting point
of a partnership if somebody you know
reads it and likes it but that's what
but needs to start somewhere
so if they ask for my email there's a
possible second date
I should assume I mean if they were
going to Chili's I mean I think that if
they have a script I mean if they get
the script release
and then they get the project you know
once you've signed it
because no one's just gonna ask for the
script and then if they read it
and they like it if you have a manager
an agent they'll talk with them and if
it's just you then you talk with the
producer and they might send you deal
terms about locking down the rights
and then you bring in you get a lawyer
and you negotiate a deal and then if you
want to work with the producer you close
out the the paperwork and now you have a
producer who's attached to the script
how would you shorten this pitch
I think that like that the delay into
the time travel
could be
a little bit streamlined because once we
get into the new location the new time
period
I think that's when the story becomes
more interesting okay so I just think
that the the way into the time travel of
it all
you know could need a little work
you're right because I look at what I
have written here that I read to you and
half of this paragraph is all set up so
okay that's a great point and thank you
for that so it I should just basically
say
I mean I I kind of want to make it seem
like this is the guy that his own
creation got him into this kind of like
a Frankenstein yeah this is a monster so
what if it's just like
a
individual experimenting with technology
goes wrong
and then it becomes the horror film
because now they're it got them in the
wrong place and it's broken so now it's
like survival
yeah I guess I want a part where he
thought he was above his own creation
and that this would never happen to him
but instead his own creation got him
yeah I think that's something that could
be elaborated but you do still need
that thesis level
pitch where you don't have all these
extra details because they could kind of
once you read the script they'll be
revealed over time but I think the key
is looking at the pitch as your trailer
and that trailer instead of like when a
movie is made as it gets you to pay for
a ticket and watch it or download it at
home or whatever stream it this instead
is the trailer is getting you to read
the script
and that's what you're verbalizing
has Hollywood run out of ideas
because you can't run out of human
experiences and everybody
who's ever born looks at the world in a
different way
why do we hear that some
that song see it in our con
hear it all the time
it seems we've run out of ideas we're
only repeating the same story or IP over
and over again
depends where you look I mean
I'm sure that
it's also a taste thing because some
movies get made more some kind of
character or genre
and there's an audience for that but
if we're adventurous
just go on letterbox like letterbox is
like the coolest
website around or app and it just has so
much exploration for movies and during
the pandemic I created a crime film club
where I would curate movies
to my friends and some of them were you
know in Asia and all around the world
and we before we hop on a zoom call we'd
watch one of these movies that I picked
and I used letterbox to find them and
every title I tried to pick something
that was
obscure and nobody's seen in the group
because there are some cinephiles
they're pretty hardcore so but then it
became like a fun challenge can I get
something that they haven't seen
and I was successful I I found multiple
movies that like the most hardcore crime
film fans didn't
ever hear of and we had incredible time
talking about them so I think the
question is are the movies that you feel
are derivative maybe it's a type of
projects you just don't want to watch
that's fine
what about you know the onus is on you
because like there's International
Cinema there's incredible storytellers
on YouTube there's so many you know
really interesting points of view or
there's podcasts that have you know
started being created in the Audio Drama
space So Stories from
you know creators that
we haven't been introduced to yet but
now they're here in a new medium so I
think that line about there isn't enough
X or whatever I think that anybody's
commenting on that they have a point to
some degree because maybe they just
don't like what's popular but then they
also have the responsibility to seek out
what they find interesting
or taking it with music since I know
you're you're a music Aficionado so a
lot of people say oh well there's no
good music and made after the 2000s or
whatever
would you say that they just haven't
looked hard enough that they haven't
found some indie bands or different
artists that they're they're still in
this mindset of what was fed to us
through radio back in the day which has
kind of gone away
I mean
maybe there's a band that they like and
they broke up or there was a movement
and
that is in the the dominant one
you know the artists are not pushing in
that space you know pushing that space
or it's not getting a lot of press
I mean I can't say don't feel bad about
the lack of the type of movies or music
or
you know writing that you've seen and if
and it you see like just a desert you
know and there's not an abundance of
options I mean you should mourn that if
that's the nostalgic quality I mean if
you miss a certain type of thing I get
that I can only speak to myself like I
can't say this is what the industry is
doing or not doing I could say that when
I was looking for movies
to entertain very cynical friends of
mine who've seen everything
and I found things that were very
inspiring that's from my own you know
experience but if there is specific
types of storytellers or stories that
you don't see that's a valid concern I
don't want to deny that I could only
talk about
within my own you know range of
experiences and you know what I've seen
but then at the same time if you don't
see what what's out there in you
it's a kind of inspiration maybe for you
as an artist because now there's more
fuel to get you
really plugged into a certain type of
thing that that's missing in some ways I
think
art is kind of a criticism if you make a
movie
that is a crime film that is directly uh
diametrically like opposed to what's out
there like if it's all about like 80s
action films and then another Style
comes out that's different or a horror
genre starts and it's all meta and
that's the thing everything's about meta
is that there's these different
movements
and sometimes a new movement upends an
old one
so if you feel you're not getting what
you want and you're a Storyteller maybe
you're the one that sees something that
needs to resurface that you like or you
see something that's not there ever and
never been there and you want to destroy
the current movement you want to put it
into the passe and this is your critique
on it then you should you should destroy
you should in a way it's like you're
kind of
becoming the next
voice that's going to resonate and you
might mean that you are in confrontation
with the current
you know fancy you know filmmaker or
author or painter and you're a necessary
part of this you know the waves that
will happen you know in our culture and
then you should bring upon change you
should fight to bring upon change but
you don't like what's out there and if
you're not a Creator you're a Critic
then you could attack what's out there
you know or if you're just a commentator
you get comment on this YouTube video
and that still will critique of
something I mean that's totally fine I
don't I don't think
it's all or one thing I think it's a
Confluence of different perspectives
he brings to mind this quote we don't
see things as they are we see things as
we are exactly so then when we complain
that there's no more good movies anymore
there's no good music anymore we can't
it's all been done before it's really
more on us it's what it's the filter
that we're seeing it through and that
maybe that means that we need to tell
those stories well I don't think people
should be able to complain about what's
out there I think that's fine I'm just
saying that
in some way
if you really don't like a certain
way a genre is being explored by the
current
you know fancy people in the space who
are getting all the attention
you might come out of left field
and completely like wreck shop on it
like there could be a there could be a
musician from SoundCloud that says I
hate what these DJs are doing now in in
electronic music they don't know what's
going on
and because of the the platforms are so
much about amplifying anything that gets
traction you might just in your parents
basement make a song that gets attention
and now you're challenging what's out
there or you make a film for no budget
it plays the festivals and then suddenly
people go oh it's not about the thing
that you don't like or if you're like I
said if you're not a filmmaker you're
just a writer you just comment on every
article you're still there you're still
present you're still pushing against
something it's okay to not be a fan of
what's out there you know I think it's
ridiculous if someone's like just smile
and consume
everything you don't have to you could
you could just be annoyed that whatever
you're really into is not being like
embraced
but then you also have the abilities to
be a thorn in the side of what's there
or potentially be a death sentence to
that movement that you don't like and
maybe not a distance in the sense that
it never could get reborn but look it
could put on hold stop it and then
challenge it with your own voice
kind of just be like a Mindless consumer
you think that's what they want from us
I don't think anybody wants to be a
Mindless consumer and I think that like
the idea that there's a Hollywood movie
and it's just
you know doesn't take thinking to make a
movie Nobody who's making movies
mindless it's incredibly challenging you
know task to do that and there's so many
people involved in the process that are
brilliant so I don't think a movie is
just Mindless and I do think that
a movie's goal is to have some type of
reaction you know it's not they don't
want an apathetic
audience that doesn't feel anything
they're they're wanting it to like
create an experience that's memorable or
at least not memorable
it makes you forget the challenges of
your life so you know I don't think that
is idea that you just pour
content down somebody's mouth
and that's uh and that's what it what
the system is it doesn't work that way
it's it's a there's all it's basically
there's all sorts of stories that are
being told and some of them being pushed
to front and center some of them are
more in the background and as time goes
they shift uh based on the what's
popular what's you know the new cool you
know the new cool voices the new cool
distributor you know what's 824 doing
and it just keeps shifting
you know but it's your job
to decide where you're participating in
it if you're commenting on it and if you
don't want anything else you just think
that it's bad it's fine too like there's
no there's no responsibility for any
individual
regarding what level of uh you know
proximity they have to this uh culture
as a Creator or a commentator
free will of course to extend
and the algorithm doesn't follow us and
I mean it depends on how you um consume
content or movies or comic books or I
mean like there's a spectrum of EX ways
that you
interact with media is it physical is it
you're super nostalgic and you get DVDs
and VHS are you getting them off Netflix
are you getting them off Criterion I
just don't think there's like a
one-size-fits all
for anybody and there isn't like just
some psychographics that defines a giant
chunk where everyone's like all you do
is watch these videos be because that's
not true I mean I listen to certain
types of podcasts
watch certain kinds of movies read
certain kinds of Journalism like I'm a
very specific in that way and there's
other people that will be all about
watching video games on YouTube or
somebody's all about food I think that
like there's this idea that like this
death of what we over of what we love or
there's nothing here or I do think that
there's ways that journalists sometimes
will create
an absolute like they'll say it's like
so I think they're creating the and
sometimes not all of them obviously but
some of them have like a frame that's
convenient because it invokes
conversation so it's like how do I how
do I say something that's bombastic to
get you talking I mean I know for a
little while uh years ago they were
saying horror movies are dead that was
like an article there is a few bombs or
whatever horror movies are dead
and then I was like how's that true when
the world at times is horrific when The
Human Experience could just be
terrifying and confusing
how could horror movies be dead yet we
need an outlet to comment on this
complex nature of our mortality so
there's no way but at the same time the
journalists maybe just want people to
talk about we're sick of schlock at war
movies and maybe that's the protest
that's the writing that's fine but I
just think that these type of frames on
the grand scheme as much as their
conversation starters if you take them
too seriously they're also limiting
we hear a lot about the 99 of
screenplays written today are quote
unquote horrible what's been your
experience with screenplays that you've
read yeah I don't think that like
that many are like just
total trash
I think that like for me when I look at
it as somebody to either like represent
a writer or the producer project that it
it's not like something is
completely
not on the level it's more
does it align with my taste so I'm not
being shocked by the the bad scripts I'm
reading and maybe I'm not being exposed
to really bad ones but for whatever ends
up on my to-do list to read it typically
is actually pretty good
there's never been anything where you
were surprised that someone would submit
something that wasn't finished
well I tend to not just take on
submissions
that the email
doesn't perk my interest I mean I have
to see a log line
of something
that makes me want to read it
and it's
presented professionally in the email or
I get a script from a trusted contact
or like a cover fly or find something on
Blacklist and it's got good feedback on
it
probably pretty good like it's not there
isn't a
incredible deviation from
what I'll mention it to be to what it is
and how horrible it is
what I rarely find is writing that gets
me in the in the mindset of
oh my God this is something that I have
to get involved with
that's the the difference it's not about
wow it's all it's all bad it's more of
like what's gonna make me care more
because I do have to look at all my
other responsibilities
what what's going to make me want to
like open up space
in my mental bandwidth and on my
schedule to really
get behind
a project that's what we're talking
about but it's not like
I'm seeing so many
bad
writers
and maybe through my filter systems
because I'm engaged with a network maybe
I'm just not seeing those
what do you think 99 of screenplays get
wrong
I don't know what they get wrong
because I don't know the ratio of
scripts that I like and then at a
certain point
it's also a tasting because they're
perfectly talented writers that will
find managers
that have different tastes than mine or
I might find a writer that some other
manager doesn't like so I can't say in
like a
as a number in a sense that this
percentage won't won't get it I could
just say that it's just my sensibilities
and those things those those things are
just like subjective and they guide my
curation so I can't tell writers to
write exactly in the in the way that I
connect with because that's their voice
and that's how they want to write so if
there's something that I fall in love
with that's great but just the stars
aligning so it's more of an organic
uh type of thing that I have as a
manager where I'm like wow this is
really special
and
this is what I want to watch on TV or I
want to see in the theater
and that's more of that subjective taste
than it is that there's just all these
bad writers making mistakes
it's in the same way like I at home I
have unlimited options uh to stream
practically
what am I choosing to watch like that's
more of a reflective of the sense of are
these do I connect with these writers or
not is why would I actually sit back and
watch what am I good at what am I gonna
enjoy on the weekend so but I don't want
to like
speak to all these writers and say look
you're all messing up as much as I have
certain tastes that
defines my uh my business
can you explain meta to me
the the sense that there is a like if
you think about I don't know uh Deadpool
there is a a commentary on the superhero
genre Within
his you know his his performances his
jokes the the character is
constantly commenting on
the the type of world that he occupies
or if you look at like Scream the
characters in some ways are commenting
on the slasher genre
so I mean that's my I guess
you know take on what medic could be I'm
sure there's ways to deconstruct that or
explore that concept but that's what
initially comes to mind
I think that's more prevalent now
I do think that was definitely a
movement in the horror genre
in the
with scream I think scream was
definitely
uh an approach but it's a device so I
mean I'm sure it's used across genres
currently
but it's hard to like say
if it's an exact
wave that is starting to become dominant
or it's picking up or it's just
part of
the you know the culture and we're just
kind of experiencing it off and on but
it's not like
there's all these meta creators that are
just driving you know this movement I
don't know
how does a writer know they're too late
to a genre like they're catching it when
it's on its way down and it's been done
too much and they think that it's a wave
they want to ride but the waves are
already about to crash
I think that like there is a Pastiche
that sometimes is popular and it's hard
to really like
have a handle on it exactly but you just
feel it it's not an intellectual thing
you feel certain things like
an ebb and flow of an approach you know
but I don't think anything ever dies
I think it's just
find another way
into
um into the minds of of creators and
audiences and maybe
it's not the trending idea
but it still exists I mean if you think
about fashion you'll see fashion
resurface all the time I mean
everything's 90s now so you know yeah
stonewash it's all about that you know
it's a good thing we save the jackets
yeah exactly so you know 90s never died
it's just there's just a
it's always been Ebbs and flows of ideas
and identities and
and types of characters and stories we
see but I don't think that anyone's too
late to their party I think the problem
sometimes is
that the the the messaging to some
script writers
is
done almost like it's a tech startup
where it's just like here's the space we
gotta occupy it oh no this is crowded or
you know and it's this very business and
very pragmatic mindset that you apply to
potentially another field but I think
that like as a writer
you should write what you love and how
much you align it with like being
pragmatic that's up to you or your reps
but I do think getting too caught up in
the the stock market or the trending of
what entrepreneurs are selling this it
starts changing
the mindset of um the creative process
and it's very hard to write a script so
if you're looking at like deadline
Hollywood or variety or any of those
things and you're like I gotta write
this or write that I think that starts
to become you're becoming more reactive
and I think that
to really develop your voice and really
build out your your portfolio it's
almost like you got to exert yourself
onto the world and take up space and
kind of push your ideas forward versus
just you know counter punching
uh
because you're just dealing with things
coming at you and I think with that
mentality you know maybe you do make
some money but you may not feel like you
really own it and you may not feel real
like it's yours and I think it's way
better
to stick to what you're actually care
about like if you really love
can't be you know
rom-coms or whatever it is and you know
all about them you should write to that
you should write to what you love
because then you know it on a more
specific level you should write what you
care about or else it's just like a
weird you know weird game and then it's
more then you're playing the business of
it but that's not going to inspire
people because you're not doing
something that you're feeling you're
doing something that you're thinking
you're thinking that is everybody loves
x or but I think you need to be able to
be comfortable with the risk when you
become a writer then when you write a
script you might not sell it and that's
fine and there's no there's no shame in
writing things that don't sell they
might become a sample but you don't want
to be constantly being informed by
Trends or thought leaders and all that
you just want to write
about
things that
you that are on your mind that you can't
get out of your mind you know and there
might be a movie that you saw when
you're younger
and in that movie is a movie that like
inspired you to get into a game and you
want to write to that but it's passe
still write to it because that's what's
getting it right it's your every time
you're in the game
and you're creating something you're
learning it's kind of like if you think
about it
like if you're a martial artist
you're not precious when you
work on your your discipline you're just
constantly
perfecting it perfecting it or if you're
a chef you're perfecting your cooking
and it's not like this is the best
cheesecake ever though and all
cheesecakes
and I can never do another one and that
is it no you're just doing it and keep
doing it and learning learning and
learning
and at a certain point
it may not be the projects that you
think are going to be the ones that sell
maybe it's further out that you've
worked worked work work worked and
instantly locks in
because you're not trying to protect
your time so much you're you're more
learning because you're making yourself
better and as you get better and better
you're better for yourself just to
generate a loan and you're also a better
collaborator because you could
articulate your thesis for uh for what
you're working on and then they connect
with that who you're working with and
just build it out so I think that it's
not about
protecting your your your time by
choosing
some get rich quick scheme over talking
about
themes talking about trauma that you've
experienced or commenting on
the types of you know TV shows you grow
up on those things should just drive you
and should be your compass that should
always get you back to what makes you
excited and just keep going back there
and go back there and not look at it as
like a cause and effect like I do this I
get that
you know because that's the problem is
that there's all these ideas of schemes
and I'm going to do this I'm gonna
make it work there's so many professions
that take a lifetime to learn and
and they are accepted you know to be a
lawyer you don't just become a lawyer
you don't get like a certificate in the
mail and so you're just a lawyer after
like a a week of studying law it's these
things take time so I think the key is
taking the pressure off your shoulders
and just accepting yourself accepting
what you love and accepting what makes
you different
and just making anything even if it's
just an iPhone video or something you
shouldn't like on Tick Tock it doesn't
matter or are you writing tweets or you
write short stories it's just getting
immersed in what you love and learning
and trying to find friends that share
the same you know sensibilities
and rinse and repeat and not thinking
like I need a manager or I need an agent
or I need this no you just need the
platform that allows you to
learn and sharpen your your perspective
and if you do these things you become
more valuable because then you become a
specialist you got to be okay with the
most competitive quality of any
storyteller
is you got to be more me than anybody
else
so that's what I'm saying it's not
saying I want to be the best writer or I
want to be the best director right no I
want to be more me
and I want to feed those needs that I
have
to obsess over
the directors that I fell in love with
the whatever is a comic Creator or the
musicians and if you live in that space
you start picking up valuable skills you
start refining that way to speak now
when they say voice it's like a
signature what is your voice but they
also say voice
because you listen to my voice you can
hear what I'm trying to say you're
connecting with me you're communicating
and it takes time
but then you communicate and it connects
if you see like your favorite TV shows
and movies and everything
you're not looking at the low light reel
of the craters you're looking at the
headlines
do you know there's a low light reel to
almost anybody
we don't always look cool the richest
people don't always look cool the most
successful artists don't always look
cool you're not seeing them
around
making stuff that nobody cares about
we only see when it just everything just
kind of clicks and then suddenly they're
like
amazing and that's a problem with like
the 30 under 30 or this and that is his
obsession with time
we got to get here before this happens
or we got to sell this project because
time's running out
we have time until you're dead you have
time so you should focus on
becoming the most you version as a
Creator and then if time goes by and
somehow that manifests into making all
this money and being the you know
looking awesome that's fine or you don't
become successful you just
became obsessed with what you love and I
don't think that's a tragedy either I
think it's a tragedy when you're trying
to do a performance art and pretend
you're somebody that you're not trying
to make things that you don't like I
think that's the real tragedy I think
that's a real waste of time